all right 608 here Monday class for
Clark County School District now the
year has been marked by plenty of
success of course but there are still
some lingering safety issues in fact
several high-profile incidents have
encouraged CCSD to add security measures
for next school year Lauren negretti
joining us live at El Dorado High where
security was increased there after a
violent attack on a teacher this last
year Lauren good morning
good morning last April a teacher was
brutally attacked by a student right
here at El Dorado High School that
prompted fences cameras and even a
single point of entry just to name a few
upgrades there well last week at a press
conference district and police leaders
announced they're looking into more
options the superintendent Metro and
ccsdpd Chiefs say they're looking into
models in place nationally namely clear
backpacks metal detectors and more
efforts they hope would catch items like
the 30 guns and nearly 200 knives
confiscated on campus this year alone
every option and the congestion caused
by some of these metal detectors office
also some of the things that we're
looking at
they pointed to the success of their
instant alert system superintendent Jara
says he asked the legislature for 21
million dollars to hire more police in
our schools so quote kids are safe and
teachers can teach those School leaders
present also
urged parents to check their students
backpacks before they leave they say
that safety is